brought to you by predator where power
meets performance
hi everyone i'm andrea rene with your
III 2017 a PC gaming roundup
brought to you by predator where power
meets performance it's been an exciting
week so far here at e3 and I've got your
top PC gaming stories
first up Bethesda had their annual III
showcase on Sunday night and if you're
an Elder Scrolls fan they announced new
content coming to the Elder Scrolls
online morwen and a news story expansion
for the Elder Scrolls legends called
heroes of Skyrim we also learned about
their virtual reality offerings which
include the standalone experience doom
VFR launching later this year
fallout 4 VR launching in October and
PlayStation revealed the elderscrolls v
skyrim VR coming first two PS VR and
while they didn't say if it was
exclusive I think all PC gamers out
there hope it's coming to oculus and
vive sometime soon the most interesting
of the Pathet news is probably the
creation club which is essentially a
paid mods system now but this ax isn't
calling it a paid mods system but
essentially what it is is an in-game
digital marketplace for Fallout 4 and
Skyrim special edition that uses a
credit system where you buy credits and
then you use those credits to buy mods
existing mods and mods created outside
the creation Club will remain free and
they won't be retrofitted to the club
and all content in the club will be
original mods that are approved curated
localized polished and tested by
Bethesda so it certainly sounds like
paid mods albeit in a roundabout kind of
way eSports seems to be the buzzword of
III this year and there's no denying the
growth of professional competitive video
games Bethesda announced the quake World
Championship quake champions was
announced at e3 last year and at
QuakeCon 2017 $1,000,000 will be up for
grabs in a tournament with the franchise
that burst the esports revolution at the
Intel press conference on Monday they
along with ESL announced the Intel grand
slam which is a competition featuring a
1 million dollar prize pool for the
first team to win 4 of the 10 major
counter strike go competition to be
clear this is a bonus prize on top of
the prize that these teams are already
going to win
pretty amazing they also announced the
VR challenger league and eSports
competition that will focus on virtual
reality it will feature insomniac the
unspoken and echo arena a VR multiplayer
game from ready at dawn which by the way
will be free for all oculus rift owners
when it releases on July 20th look for
the single-player campaign lone echo on
the same release date the VR Challenger
League will culminate in 2018 with a
championship at the Intel Extreme
Masters in Poland fire axis announced a
MIDI XCOM 2 expansion called war of the
chosen it promises new environments new
enemies and new XCOM forces three
champions will be featured who will grow
and strength throughout the game as they
learn new skills and abilities there are
also new zombie like hordes of creatures
called The Lost that will attack alien
and humans so look out plus there are
resistance groups to win over most
importantly fair access set it is easily
twice the size of the last expansion so
you're going to have lots to get your
hands on on August 29th there is no
denying player unknowns battlegrounds is
taking twitch by storm
creator Brendan Green took the stage to
announce some changes that are coming to
the game according to game spots Alex
Newhouse one of the most significant
additions the ability to vault over
objects this will likely make fans very
happy as current mechanics make it
extremely difficult to get over fences
rocks and other small obstacles as a
result it can be frustrating to navigate
through the map in addition the studio
is making new weather effects for the
game right now the map features only
clear skies or downpour but there will
soon be sunset and fog variants as well
green emphasized they want to focus on
stabilizing the game overall but rest
assured fans that yes mods will be
coming to player unknown battlegrounds
sometime in the future Microsoft is
reviving a PC classic with Age of
Empires definitive edition this special
version marks the 20th anniversary of
the series and is a full 4k remaster of
the original game it features new and
improved gameplay Xbox Live powered
multiplayer and a fully remastered
soundtrack that means new levels of zoom
people every asset has been remade
including modernizing the UI and adding
a front system head to their website for
details about the upcoming beta coming
later this
lastly Activision and Bungie finally
announced a release date for the PC
version of destiny 2 they debuted a new
cinematic story trailer at Playstations
press conference on Monday night but
later confirmed the PC offering will
launch on October 24th over a month
after the console versions released in
September it will be available via
battlenet and will even get a beta
scheduled for sometime in late August
look for more details on that coming
soon and that's your III 2017 PC gaming
roundup you can find more details on all
of these stories and a whole lot more
from e3 right here on GameSpot and if
you guys are playing the 21 X scavenger
hunt look for your next clue at the end
of this video and be sure to visit 21 X
hunt com for more details
I'm Andrew overnight and thanks for
watching